the Mazda mx-5 has had an enthusiastic
following of fans for more than a
quarter of a century until now the
little convertibles trademark has been
its soft top which can be closed and
opened while driving and folds away
nicely and tightly behind the driver yes
now Mazda has released a different
design the RF retractable fastback the
soft top has made way for a metal roof
that can be quickly folded back turning
the mx-5 into a target op says car
tester Ronnie let's see what advantages
and disadvantages the new design entails
all your stuff like mini ones by an
intestine like an owl and Shawn
[Music]
the soft-top roadster which remains in
production offers a choice of two
gasoline engines but the fastback comes
only with the most powerful of them it
produces 118 kilowatts of power and
launches the car from 0 to 100 and 7.5
seconds
[Music]
[Applause]
Ronde says the engine doesn't reach its
maximum of 200 Newton meters until you
reach 4600 rpm so you have to break the
habit of driving at low revs after all
this is a naturally aspirated engine not
a turbo which would provide top torque
at just 1400 for 1500 rpm so with the RF
get used to driving with plenty of revs
and you'll have plenty of fun
and this is what the beating heart under
the hood looks like a two-liter
direct-injection gasoline engine
[Music]
our model has a sports suspension with
beer steins shock absorbers as part of a
special optional package costing another
1,800 euros in Germany in front and
below the shoulder line the new mx-5 RF
looks like the old mx-5 the changes are
above that line the roof fins give the
fastback its sporty Targa like look they
remain in place even when the front and
middle sections of the three-part roof
disappear completely behind the seats at
the touch of a button
[Music]
the RF is the first Mazda model to
feature the power retractable roof it
takes about 13 seconds for the various
elements of the roof to fold up or down
in an elegant piece of choreography
the driver can follow the little ballet
performance on a display too bad the
depiction of the car doesn't reflect the
real cars color
[Music]
rear-wheel drive ideal 50:50 weight
distribution between front and back and
a low center of gravity make this car
fun even on country roads we're driving
the version with a six-speed manual
transmission but for 1900 euros more you
can get a 6-speed automatic the RF has
kept its soft top brother short crisp
gear throws and with it that roadster
feeling the roof can be retracted while
you're driving but it works only it
speeds up to 10 kilometers an hour so
enjoy the view at your leisure says Rani
before it gets dark
and as long as no one behind you gets
too impatient
so would Ronnie prefer the soft-top
roadster or the fastback with a
retractable metal roof
that monsta a mixing face the mx-5 RF is
a purist car says Ronnie no question
about it
but it is clearly more comfortable than
the soft options
maybe you can't go for broke and the
curves like in the Roadster but it has
another appealing quality the metal roof
means the RF is better insulated so it's
superior to the mx-5 for driving in
winter let's roll some of the inventor
fun though be exact
yeah kind of special and Germany the are
have cost two thousand seven hundred
euros more than the soft top roadster
not too bad for extra all-weather
pleasure
[Music]
[Applause]
you